[Music]
hey everyone welcome to episode 24 of
GameSpot after docking spots official
podcast I'm back it's very nice to be
back but it feels weird being on video
you're so far away from me I mean this
is closer than we usually sit in the
office oh sure you're so close to me now
I engineered it this way yay oh I met
Lucy James losing my voice apparently
joined on the couch by Michael hi oh
hello tomorrow say hi II shunned excite
ki hello yeah so it's been a while since
I've been here maybe I think the last
time I was on an episode of the podcast
was staffed December give us a
day-by-day play of what you've been
doing since then first I got up and I
had a piece of toast what kind of toast
well what's the great ol Peep Show joke
where they say I have one slice of white
and one slice of brown select one for
Maine and one for the pudding as
incredibly don't y'all fry bread too
fried bread is that is in like french
toast oh so you have that here too oh
[ __ ] I don't know no I I was traveling
for a bit and then I went home to the UK
for three weeks and then I got back and
I was in the office for a whole two days
and then I got really sick my roommates
got really sick and now Kurt in Davina
is sick scratchy scratchy something's
going around but the good news is that
I'm back at least mm-hmm this is your is
your first time in this room recording
this thing we've
courted the pockets in him and I was sat
over there but it was that's right there
was the the Yakuza zero of podcast
pretty cool hmm why not is good though
no no no yes tree it's a perfect game
some may say so may say it's a perfect
game is that why is everyone jump from
zero to seven that's why it's Netflix in
series just came out so who would you
cast as cosmic you yeah or Paul Rudd
no no racial boundaries it's Scarlett
Johansson I'd hate to see it in I can't
think of anyone I'm not familiar with
enough Japanese I mean ideally I would
hope it'd be sexual chef for these
people I would hope it was an actual
Yakuza you telling me cosmic URI is not
real they could they could get that
Australian man who's got the actual
character you tattoo on his back yeah
but he's still an Australian dude isn't
he right yeah but he's at least got the
tattoo imagine Australian cousin Mikey
maybe Edmund Tran who knows a new friend
could do cousins Carrie close enough I
know I want to see ed mature and get
like mad Brawley like slug I think ma
Jima better David Alaska David Alaska
looks exactly like macho Wow deep
gamespot CBS yeah so I mean what have
you guys been doing playing this week
oh haha let me go first cuz I got some I
got some things of takis
you know what this is the first time
it's on video so I am going to mention
five fancy fourteen so any new listeners
if you didn't listen to the audio
podcast y'all can know what it is what
my deal is
cuz yo I got a lot you know I can just
see one tear coming down
no like Mike Michael's cheek in like
five minutes when he says oh you know
it's funny uh shots out to Jason I he
follows me on Twitter but he was like
hey sorry Sam pie I can't get in some I
bought the game and I can't get into my
account either so long you hate to see
it um Tokyo Mirage sessions sharp Fe
encore just came out on switch by the
time you are listening to this podcast
is coming out Friday and I have been
playing that not doing a full review
because it's essentially a rerelease of
Tokyo Mirage sessions which came out
2016 on the Wii U but it's pretty cool
that it's on switch because who had it
with you we we we we we I did we but
yeah Toki watch it oh man I got a lot of
feelings about this game because I say
this to everyone that if you Tokyo
Mirage sessions on paper sounds like a
game that was custom-made for my
[ __ ] like there was a focus group
and I was the only one in the focus
group and this is what came out of it
it's got Jay pops got j-rock it's God
Miku references its Fire Emblem times
isn't it no wow
shut up the TV and it's God also it's
based its foundation is shin megami
tensei like the whole gameplay
foundation can you repeat your tweet
from the other day please
about what oh did you know that TMS
Tokyo Mirage sessions backwards is smt
Shin Megami Tensei oh no no it's Tokyo
Mirage Tokyo Mirage sessions shard are
Fe encore and this isn't a Square Enix
game no it's got intense Square Enix and
ten Square Enix titling energy yeah so
let me get to how I feel about it have
any any all played this when it was on
the Wii you know I friend the podcast
about the see the day and he 100 percent
today on the Wii U he said oh damn I
think yesterday he said it was in his
top 10 games no no he said it was the
third best persona game yeah hey boy I
used to look up to Andrew go for Eddie
he is cancelled and you hate to see it
now I'm just I'm just kidding uh but
yeah talking about sessions on paper I
should love this game but it's just
there's something about it that's
missing the yeah like the story the way
the the way the events play out like all
of it doesn't this doesn't tie together
so in the beginning your homegirl is
trying out to be an idol gets lost in
this alternate universe which is kind of
like it's called the idlest fear which
is like the meta verse and then you go
in there and then you have the power of
mirages which are basically personas and
then Crom is your persona or your Jojo
Stan and then you fight monsters and
then your friend who's be trying to
become popstar you save her well both of
y'all can transform and then you have
new outfits and there's a crowd cheering
and then you're like beating the [ __ ]
out of monsters and then you get out of
the car watching you yeah you know it's
kind of like persona 4 dancing all night
but an RPG instead of a rhythm okay it's
got that kind of vibe when you're in
those dungeons and weird fights but like
gameplay wise it's great because they do
some cool tweaks with the combat system
with session attacks which is like if
you like in smt when you you hit someone
with a weakness you get an extra turn
right and you can pile that on and in
persona baton pass and persona 5 and all
that stuff so there's but here is called
session tax so if you hit someone with a
weakness and you have session skills
attached to other party members they
will start to pile on on the same turn
so you can hit a weakness boom this
person comes in boom this person comes
in and then you basically have like a
three hit combo in one turn and that's
really fun to pull off and it looks
his games got a lot of style like it
looks nice to see in motion but man that
story is wack I'm sorry to say it but
it's just it's I don't know I've only
played like about 1215 hours at this
point by I'm gonna see it through
because it's an atlas joint and I got to
do my due diligence so what kind of
personas do they have again so who else
you have kromm yacht Darja that's coming
yeah yeah and then uh damn I forgot
they're all they're all Fire Emblem
characters they all Fire Emblem Murphy
what's her name the big one purple hair
[Laughter]
yonder a girl who cares why she a big
one
man I don't know what y'all talk about
she is feminine and sultry with a
calming serene nature ordering on
whimsical and massive tits yeah
but men I'm still playing that game and
I don't know it's it's fun I'll say that
much but it's it's missing that that
heart that's sold that kind of drives
the story because and I think about I
play a lot of JRPGs as does my jam and
there's always a reason to care about
what's happening in those games and all
whether it's like very simple I think
about like SMT for and how he's sick of
the premises but I can follow it I know
what the what I'm fighting for and I see
how events tie together but this are
like I don't know you save your sister
who's been missing for five years she's
a secretary now and cool she's back I
ain't seen her in five years bloody she
got a job
most people don't how
the soundtrack it's pretty good it's
pretty good but the thing with
soundtracks is there's another thing is
that for me a soundtrack really has to
communicate what is also being portrayed
on screen like you can't just be good
music when I think about persona
soundtracks I think about how those are
also integral to what's happening what
people are what characters are feeling
of how intense a battle is I think about
battle themes and boss themes a lot
these these are good songs and if the
cutscenes are incredible - the anime
cutscenes in this game are incredibly
well animated it's like it reminds me of
looking at love live performances and
love live anime and but I mean like what
for like why but why but why though I
keep asked and that's the number one
question I'm playing Tokyo Mirage
sessions but why though so it doesn't
make a lot of sense but uh-huh it's fun
still having fun and I people have been
asking should I play this game and I
think that I would say it's on the lower
of the priority list in terms of RPGs
because if you're going to invest 50 to
60 hours in a game you would probably be
like you want a bet on liking it yeah so
I mean if you haven't played Fire Emblem
3 houses if you haven't played persona 5
or if you haven't played I don't Final
Fantasy 14 trails of cold steel hmm I
would recommend those ahead of TMS but I
mean like if you're looking for
something that's cool and fun to take on
the go on your switch and you want you
have your each for them JRPGs like hey
you know Tokyo Mirage sessions might
scratch that itch a little bit but no
it's not the best game but I it's good
I'm having fun sweet yeah speaking of
trails of cold steel actually that's a
first so the the last time I was on this
podcast I had mentioned that I started
trails of cold steel and I was liking it
guess how I feel now if you graduated to
being obsessed with it oh yeah
it's the jam 2020 man I'm telling you
and I was talking about how in the past
four years I found something new to
latch on to it was persona then was
Yakuza then was Final Fantasy 14 this
year oh boy it's trails and cold steel
man and at first because I talked about
how at first it was as animate ropey
it's got like all the our character
archetypes but man that game is
incredible at giving these characters
backstory in a very efficient manner so
it doesn't get drawn it doesn't get
brought down in long exposition and
rather says okay this is where this
characters come it comes from your gonna
go visit that area and story things are
going to happen in the area so you
simultaneously progress in the story but
it also ties to the characters origins
so you get two birds with one stone as
the story progresses and I'm almost done
with cold steel one and I'm already I
feel like I know these characters so
well and this is a four-part series so
if I'm invested now
boy we got our we got cold steel to
installed ready to go as soon as I'm
finished one and I have cold steel three
on ps4 man man and these these are long
games to that like 50 60 hour JRPGs and
I'm loving it it's you know it's a silly
it might as it might look and how that
you know some people look at JRPGs my
god it's nonsense like now like this
game is pretty well grounded in terms of
what it's trying to tell like it's got
full boy it's got daddy issues it's got
its but not so much it's got some bad
dads and it's like the dangers of
militarization a lot of political drama
and a lot of it touches on classism in
some smart ways not in like the most
groundbreaking ways but it's really
smart about how it talks about nobility
and aristocracy compared to commoners
and their role in society and how the
youngins are kind of like I don't really
I don't really that I don't doesn't make
sense to me but then all the older
people be like no this is how it's got
to be so there's a lot of tension in
there that
genuine and it's very much earned on top
of being a very good RPG man that games
got some real good characters so man I
you know it's fairly nice one of those
once you've broken through the surface
of the JRPGs when you want to get real
day with JRPGs you know when you want to
get real do awesome yeah not that mine
if you want to get like I'm doing
Neptune yeah that is that is if you get
real dirty come to my desk I have a pile
there's a pilot just says all the
Neptunia games yeah yeah trails cold
steel it just got localized recently but
they are like the first I think the
first few games were meant to they are
Vita games so I'm playing them on PC and
of course they look like Vita games on a
PC on PC but it has ultra wide support
so a man amigos ultra wide yeah relax
but yeah I am absolutely in love with
cold steel and expect to hear from me
throughout the entire year about the
trails of cold steel you heard it here
first
that's it yeah I do and lastly final
value 14 I did the New Year event and
it's really good because you say you're
the rat and a people are like hey the
rats stole our mochi and they're like
well we want to make mochi to celebrate
the new year and then you're like damn
we're the mochi at and they need to find
out that the rats didn't steal a mochi
but the mochi the mochi turned into a
monster and then you got to go out in
the world and then do this this fate
quest if you play for a faster 14 you
know what I'm tomba you do a fake quest
where you fight though this giant evil
mochi and then once you destroy it I
think I I don't know I think you bring
back the mochi and then you make it and
then everyone's happy does do the rats
get justice for being falsely accused I
yeah and then I think the the people who
were blaming the rats were like a you
only so bad after all
yesterday we discovered that Michael is
actually a incredibly casual Final
Fantasy player who is you casual yeah
cuz like we were like me and Ben were
just chatting
just like been just had the idol camera
on you know what I don't care my mouse
over like what's this like it's the idol
coming I see Lala fell I see cat girls
yeah what's going on because like the
idol camera is really cool in that game
it'll like start moving around different
people in the area anyone who's doing
something interesting to try and give
you like this cinematic cuz yeah it's
got the cinematic bar yes so be like oh
it's gonna cut to someone who's dancing
or there's like a little dog walking
around this flower bed area or cut to
that he walked off and he was like what
I can't know everything I place the 450
hours of that game it sits in the main
menu yeah she be asleep land it's not
time to be idle ya know I need to go on
Ben's level my man's automated
everything yeah sitting there watching
his character but yeah yeah but yeah
final phase 14 still hidden oh man this
new update coming in February Oh stick
the game spot for all that sweet
coverage you know and if you want to
listen to me cry about shot the end of
shadow breakers I highly suggest you go
back to the episode where we had max
Scoville audio-only unfortunately so you
couldn't see the but the twinkle in my
eye but uh yeah that's that's what I'm
doing man I am deep in my [ __ ] and I
love it getting me access to my account
back sorry damn we've been playing and
doing a little bit of everything I've
been slowly making my way through the
Witcher Netflix series oh yeah I like it
I like two days at my mum's house yeah I
on the couch just what's the thing and
then my mum came in when I was on
Episode four and did the classic mum
thing of who's that who's she
why is he in a bathtub who's that hello
does he have magic powers and am i I'm
not doing this no I'm not doing this no
no you could just tell her read the last
wish and then we'll talk but I've been
enjoying you know the timeline stuff is
a bit wacky I did you read about the
explanation though cuz when the
showrunner explained it I was way more
forgiving of it I don't think it was the
explanation in
wouldn't meet certain characters like
Siri until midway through so unless they
fudge the timeline I agree and there
there are certain like late story
revelations that kind of hit yeah
because of the way they messed with the
time stuff I'm cool with that
it's the part where they don't explain
they don't explain it so there you'll go
like three episodes in thinking it's all
happening either same around the same
time and then you like suddenly like
wait this doesn't line up and then
you're like all this takes place
like they really should just added like
a year a lot of one scene where Daryl
just appears in another characters
section I was like there's a telling
when they actually had to release that
timeline after yeah I have no issue with
them doing it out of order I just like
add that you just needed like a bit of
text to say like 15 years and totally
over but regardless I still find it to
be I think it's really like approachable
as a fantasy series which is surprising
given the heritage and the history and
baggage that The Witcher series has
there's so much content that you can
consume of it but if you're like Game of
Thrones is finished that last season was
hot garbage of what can I get to get
some Game of Thrones vibes and that
doesn't have like specific Game of
Thrones wells but it's got like that
world kind of building interesting
fantasy universe like in a way more
digestible and more immediately fun and
enjoyable way if not lot loads of
episodes of like political machinations
and political you know movements that
eventually build up to you know this big
battle or something it's like Carol's
got a sword now watch this and it's got
some of the best sword play in in any
like anything I've seen it's really cool
episode one's like super strong for it
did you see there's someone recut they
didn't recut they just put on Britney
Spears to see yeah
but yeah like I'm working my way through
and I really like how like it's it's a
great like one and done show where you
can watch one episode and be like that
was good I'm gonna enjoy it feels like
watching or playing a really good side
quest in The Witcher every time yeah
like it always ends with like a moral
choice yeah it always ends in like a a
kind of our choice needs to be made by
Carol and it will have ramifications but
and like it doesn't the larger plot
doesn't seem very obvious until very
late in but you get like an interest
it's always like Daryl rolls into a new
town and ex person needs help and
situation that seems initially quite
simple bad person doing bad thing
quickly becomes complicated and then
there's like a bit of romance is you
know some new de and sword-swinging
someone gets killed and by the
incredible tits yeah some good
breasteses or we are renaming episodes
cuz oh that's it seems to be a thematic
fit what's-her-face from Fire Emblem and
Camilla yeah yeah also a well-rounded
series I'm like dudes get it out as well
well not perhaps not as like graphically
they would in what do you mean some
wings yeah no there's no Wang's in it
there's a lot of henry cavill in the
boss he's great as Geralt was rising
clearly like this is one of those
situations where you know how any time
an actor takes on and like an iconic
role from another media they're like oh
yeah I really care about this property
it means a lot to me like yeah sure I if
you just watched his performance you'd
be like yeah this guy knows the which he
likes The Witcher yeah did you see uh he
was being interviewed in the junket and
someone said oh you xbox of this 40 when
I'm busy baby there's another video from
back in the day where he talks about it
what overwatch character he made any
preface is thereby being like
and
humble pie realities character I think
this is you know a lot of value in it
and it eventually ends in Symetra and
like people are just like a Symetra the
the what character would offer our
character but yeah I really enjoyed it
and his voice is real good like he's not
Doug caca but who else cam you know can
be you know the original voice actor for
now he's iconic but he gets there yeah
like there's moments where he's quoting
the game word-for-word and you're like
to ask yeah just good real gamer out
there playing I haven't heard a wind
howling you know unfortunately not it's
a season to hold on to there needs to be
a wind howling so I staff to watching
that I dipped back into the Witcher 3 to
kind of play bits there here and there
and I'm enjoying that I started playing
on ps4
I finished it on PC and I started
playing on ps4 with a fresh save so
we'll see how long I stick with that but
I'm enjoying it for now I'm dipping in
and out of deaf stranding still stinging
little bits of you know deliveries here
and there more recently it's been like
well we I've been playing shovel knight
load yes so a little bit yeah so that
like I said last time Rainbow six siege
yeah that's pretty much it that's what
I've been I've kind of like I'm taking
the calm before the storm to just play
games I've already played and games that
I'm not like super invested in right now
like the over watches and the siege
isn't that kind of stuff because I know
once the you know the big game start
hitting they're gonna hit like fast yeah
big game juice coming up in here so
enjoying that and yeah just I kind of
stuff my hair academia watching that had
some budget spent on it oh that's some
animation in there is you know this
motions moments in my hair academia
where you can be like yeah they animate
this so hard that the lighting takes a
hit like the screen gets dimmer and you
like it they physically full-colour is
to wait for the blu-ray release well you
can get like viv then none but like
there's moments like your streaming
compression just cannot handle it like
the actual like every version of it like
there's a scene in the first season
which there's a fight between two
characters it's polar Aki and Deku and
they're like both do their abilities at
each other
oh yeah thing and if you watched any
stream diversion of that as those two
abilities about to hit like it just gets
slightly darker cuz they're like no we
can't do this stupid like right like
that latest episode it's got a big fight
in it and it's like oh let's crank this
down a bit yeah I'm excited to see that
as we're a with all the colors but yeah
so my hero academia continues to be one
of the coolest anime shows around TV
shows around even yeah that's pretty
much it
John Nick uh watch butcher which is very
good this is tam mentioned played a
little bit of Final Fantasy 14 because I
did pick it up Oh tell me more well so I
played about I played it like three four
times now and I can't play more than an
hour before I have to turn it off
because I am reborn I'm in that realm
reborn nonsense
it is fetch quad sense wow it is dude
dialogue it's not great I am willing to
put up with I'm willing to get to the
good stuff because people keep like I am
not doubting stuff we're doing this
because we believe you yeah yeah it is
this is a real rough go this is the
thing that that hooked me into realm
reborn though was 90 hours of trash the
music the music's good I'll admit the
music is pretty good though like how
beautiful the environments are all right
you're the the the how much you love
your character I you have to make it you
love oh yeah I've gotta say goes
takis Fuego yeah love takis Fuego he's
trapped in European services damn and
yeah that's got the me coat a catgirl
scene I'm saying yeah yeah the program
had I been and his
like playing with me very very
graciously we're like never just like
they're just like yeah man this really
stuffs trash wait you said so Ben's
automated a bunch of stuff can you not
just do that to get through all the by
like a skip that just gets you to
another expansion that I'm 15 bucks you
know what I wouldn't I wouldn't be
opposed to it though because I think
what saved ROM reborn for me was
actually the lasts I don't know 10
quests of the pre heavensward
like the post the patched in quests that
lead into heavens were the first
expansion are what really sold me on the
struggles that are happening in that
world because then it's like okay all
the stuff that we've been telling you
we're telling you telling we're showing
you what the lay of the land is okay now
we're gonna flip the switch and then now
you're gonna now you're gonna see why
we've been telling you about all the
[ __ ] this whole time and then that's
when I was like it clicked for me and
I'm like damn that's wild I can't wait
to see what happens next then the ball
starts rolling so I mean if you maybe
maybe you can just like maybe watch the
is that gonna hit if if you skipped all
the way to the front
that's kinda what I'm wondering about
not all these three expansions are full
games though like rapids were storm blow
shadow bringers are 50 our experiences
alone so maybe I'll do it maybe I'll
just grind I don't get that because you
bought the the complete set I did yeah
so I have everything yeah although my 30
days subscription did run out so like I
said just they hit me up oh I'll cash a
Pew oh and I'll pay for your
subscription bro amen yeah paying three
subscriptions right now you wanna and
Jake Jake so I'm actually considering
opening up two more slots so if you all
want to play Final Fantasy 14 get your
subscription paid for I still pay for
mine so cuz I actually wish my
subscription fee was higher psych I'm
just kidding I'm gum good I guess you
know Showtime money what are you playing
this cat girl no
lancer okay Lance is fun I heard I heard
you can do like weird flips and yeah
what's he become Brown what's he become
dragon sounds like sounds pretty cool
but otherwise the main thing I've been
playing is Mass Effect 3
yeah I've been playing that so a couple
years ago when Andromeda came out I
played through one and two with my
girlfriend who'd never played them loved
them then and drama came out for some
reason we kind of fell off Mass Effect
for a little bit after you because I had
it like an early copy and I was like and
then so she was watching it she was
watching me play it I hundred percent of
that game dramedy
yeah 60 hours of Lee say I do not like
that game I really take days off work I
took a day off for Andromeda damn wasted
days off it's funny I was like kinda in
denial like went like in the office
people like what do you think about I'm
like I like it
yeah and then it was like you liked it
and then like four days later I'm like
alright I don't like it time you and I
went to EA in Guild feds to do the hands
on the first hands on of Andromeda and
we both came out reeling that felt
really good man they dropped you in like
six hours we were kind of like oh it's
fine it's a Mass Effect game I'm sure
they'll explain the story and I'll love
it appreciate all these characters but I
forget that Ryan thank you for that one
character I forgot the name the pilot
and like she has this amazing sequence
where she talks about like religion and
the stars and stuff and I remember
writing a preview by Anakin this is like
he weighed that this is like oh is it
yeah African I forgot name II don't
remember any I don't remember any I
remember PB and that's it
Cora like or a close enough I can't I
cannot remember you writing I'm a
believe you Drac Drac school he's just
grumpy or the problem is I walk into a
room one two those Ford racks and yeah
and everything
which was my drag
oh jeez Joel yeah yeah Lexi who was in
Game of Thrones
no I don't like I didn't play in Drammen
I played Mass Effect 3 oh yeah
it's really it's real good Sufi oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah okay great with I I
haven't played three for a few years I
do I do want to go back yeah
so I I plead I've only played it twice
compared to like the ten times I played
Mass Effect one and two and full
disclosure I was one of those people
that really did not like the ending when
it came out um I wasn't wrong and I
didn't yeah I wasn't gonna do that but I
was definitely discussions about well
yeah I I've definitely been I was
disappointed in the ending and I felt
like it didn't live up to kind of like
the standard that Bioware I'd set up but
as like the DLC came out and I feel like
it's kind of shitty disable like kind of
patched some of that like it's not great
but like when you kind of come back to
it and you and you don't really care as
much about that you'd you're like yeah
it makes a little bit better and I think
Citadel kind of like that was such a
make good deal Sam service so going back
to it now is kind of like really
eye-opening where it's like I've been
away from it I've accepted Mass Effect 3
for what it is
I'm just kind of enjoying it on its own
terms and oh I really I'm really
enjoying it yeah it's it is probably the
most fanservice II Bioware game I've
ever played but in like a really good
way like that that sounds bad but it's
like every mission every moment every
line is like a callback to something
else you did like you know from like big
obvious stuff like oh did you save you
know the rack and I are not to like yeah
I you know did this one random
side-quests and Mass Effect one like
that was cool like I had a moment where
I've had characters acknowledged
different romances I did for both Mass
Effect one and two like like Jack
acknowledged that I romanced Garris and
then Rex acknowledged that I
romantically are in Mass Effect one and
separate conversation so like I love
that they it like there's that much
detail in it because I remember a lot of
people being like oh you're there's not
as many choices in Mass Effect 3 and
it's it's I mean there are but it's more
that like it's just paying off
everything it's more like the algorithm
behind the scenes is calculating
everything you did in those last two
games and then applying that throughout
that whole game and so it's just like
every moment is like this cool reference
to like a thing you did it just feels so
rewarding
I started playing together that's the
other game I was playing as Mass Effect
one because it's on game paths and like
I'm trying to do that thing where I
diverge and play differently mm-hmm and
each time I just come back to oh I'm the
same way I'm just like gotta do that
exact same path even when you know
exactly what's gonna happen it still
hits and then damn is so good and like
that the third game is all about the
culmination of all that right yeah and I
think that's why I was way more
forgiving back then about the choices
and that kind of stuff and I was like
it's what about how he wraps up yeah
right yeah it's been it's been a lot of
fun to replay that game and it makes me
like really want that remaster that we
make that that's something obviously
oh man cuz like I'm playing it backwards
compatible on xbox which is nice but
it's like I need it I need you know what
if you get them upgraded textures and
that native 4k 60fps what it has Shepard
they really sound a way to kind of like
merge those games together and it's like
one big game I mean I don't know I was
thinking about that like how feasible
that because those games do have like
different mechanics to them that might
be a little tough but like even just
like I don't know like like like just a
consistent visual you know like yeah
over the border or like like for example
if you play female Shepard
they didn't add a default Shepard like
character model until three and which is
like crazy and so like it could you give
me that because I actually really like
the way she looks and I'm like can you
give me that back into like one and two
or like put the combat of like three
into one like definitely tighten up the
combat from one yeah yeah but it's also
weird there's like things that happen
the plot that would make like a playing
it almost
sequentially a bit weird right that's
why I think like you couldn't 100% do it
that way because because you do like
other certain things that change and it
wouldn't quite line up but they tweeted
today like about the mass effect relays
[Music]
the anniversary of when they discovered
the relays or two on the 26th
yeah and they I know for n7 they kept
being like hey you know we still just a
lot of stories to tell in the Mass
Effect universe imma do it then you
cowards right exactly they know
particularly or everyone at byword knows
like people just want Mass Effect's
they're also pretty probably fans of it
as much as we exactly and you could tell
they want it as well like so it's just
like I mean the question is are they
actually working on something or exists
is them trying to like desperately be
like maybe if our tweets get enough
attention we can show this to someone a
I don't like hypothetical do you really
want the Bioware that we have now to be
working on a new Mass Effect I know but
the bio way that made anthem and the bio
way that made by where do you want the
ei that's a good question because I
still think that they could make them an
amazing they could - and I think like
the problem we have is like they need to
be left alone for a little while
I dunno backseat developing yeah I don't
I think I think honestly I think if they
wanted to get some goodwill I think an
easier project would be the remaster
he's like hey just get your feet wet you
know like do them in like a nice like HD
you know we we've been doing like the
GameSpot what next year predictions and
I swear in 2018 as a the old mass spec
remasters and I think crisper in 2019
said mass spec remaster 2020 said mass
spec yeah you got like you have to keep
wishing it yeah it's like that in which
will in two souls remaster and keep
saying it so how do you like what a
point doing that's that's my view
why I think about what blue points doing
demon souls your master taught my life I
reckon they got a massive egg my
prediction is blue point comes down
they're like listen wait I think it's I
think that we made our own game no no
they said it was another remaster and
they said it was gonna blow people's
minds like they're like it's gonna be
exciting I do their own game as well I
would love to see what their own game is
but hey all of your games hey hey you
know else blue point remastered before
they could do a remake of shadow boluses
Snake Eater yes some may say that the
the best version of Snake Eater is the
3s version I mean I played the DS
version yeah okay
I only play ps3 yeah damn that's cool
relax
I saw me say Mass Effect 3 is the best
in the trilogy I'm not saying that it's
me I like I love Mass Effect 3 a lot
because that whole game felt like an
ending yeah yeah like that's kind of
what y'all was saying play ugly cry did
like it in review oh yeah is great yes
oh we want to Remo who knew all right
I've been
despite traveling a lot like flying back
to the UK and stuff I haven't really
played a lot of games Lucy James doesn't
games
exactly yeah it's it's my brand it's
actually a fraud I did watch a bunch of
movies I watched The Farewell which was
really great oh oh a shout-out to my
Asian Games great I watch Little Women I
want you to know I mean I texted Mike
Mahadi
annihilation apologist Thursday so I was
super sick and I was so sick just I was
so sick that I didn't
I watched the retry
rkg boys were doing this out last
playthrough and it was too loud for me I
was too singing out loud
smoking
I texted Mike and I said is annihilation
and kid film and he replied yeah
he replied is this a joke and I said no
as in like is it a good time to watch
and I'm sick is it loud and he said no
it's not it always until maybe the
ending that's now you know you're really
sick when you're like actively asking
for Mike mahadji's opinions you enjoy a
lot of it there was some bits where I
was just kind of glazing over a bit but
I didn't of those because I was sick
going on I have I it's weed that I'm
gonna mention this but it's because I
want to talk about it more next week
when I've actually had a proper chance
to watch it but the outsider started on
HBO which is the new it's a Stephen King
he got canceled and then he sort of
uncounseled himself but he's that's not
for him to decide yeah questionable to a
presidency other day anyway
it's Stephen King but it's Ben
Mendelsohn and Jason Bateman and some my
favorite Jason Bateman is obvi I love
Arrested Development Jason Bateman is
incredible in Arrested Development but
the best Jason Bateman is scary as [ __ ]
Jason Bateman so if you've seen the gift
or even ozark he can play a terrifying
person really really well and I think
it's because you sort of know him as the
oh he's Michael Bluth he's a
happy-go-lucky dad who just wants the
best for his son so when he plays he's
more psycho psycho psycho tech roles
it's terrifying and he's really really
good at it so I started watching it last
night but I had a beer and no dinner yet
and so I started watching it and it was
like oh this is no this is way too
intense for me right now so I'm gonna
stop and also this is OK the whole thing
is about a kid who's murdered oh and I
thought they would sort of do the
regular show
you know oh it's a kidney married we're
not gonna show too much of it on screen
uh nobody I picked up my might take away
my door - got ordered and I unpause the
bloody TV show and that was like just a
dead child and I was like oh okay no
I'll come back to it
you had a series of unlucky
recommendations for the mood that you
were in each time that's unfortunate
because we obviously have the three-day
weekend so I'm gonna watch the first
three episodes and I watched all of
killing Eve first - that's how you kill
an evening
you're better than that actually you're
not
Tim Wow yeah yeah I mean I watch killing
Eve first season way better than the
second the second season was a [ __ ]
like okay it's just like an mi5 agent
and an assassin he kind of watched the
time lines at the same time and you know
the mi5 agents trying to catch the
assassin the assassins going about doing
a business I mean it was it was like
it's fine I watched the whole things
were you getting these wreck are you
just like how are you coming across
these things are you getting them
recommended stuff that I want to watch
that I hear is good and I wanted to
watch killing you because I like fleabag
Phoebe wall operation do you have a
running list of anime beyond things like
my hero I started watching Cowboy Bebop
again okay you've never finished it
though have you no I think there's only
ever like two episodes that I never
watched I would never watch the end of
the series um do you know how tense no
oh good yeah I imagine being in 2020 and
not having cowboy revolvers do you know
about Aaron Sampson
and how he he didn't Aaron Sampson cute
we found out he's producer he's got like
three kids he's like one of the older
producers in the office he's been but
apparently slowly watching Cowboy Bebop
for the last decade what how so - year
and and he was like last year's telling
us like yeah I think I'm finally gonna
finish it and he's like even remember
stuff he was like I forget it did he not
know there was a second season or he was
like he's a guy I heard they cancelled
it you know never did a second season
that's real bummer or whatever like he
had no idea I was like
you didn't know man's didn't know yeah
he's a oh that was really adorable
middle I think oh yeah he was telling
talking to me about yeah I don't know
he's watching with his kids because yeah
stealth stealth weebs playing shovel
knight so audio locks is running on
gamespot right now so we've done death
trending control justice colleseum we've
got gears v this weekend which is
actually one of my I'm not a
particularly a huge gears person like
played it you like you'd never Fame that
armor no my neck is but I've never
really been you know hugely hugely
invested in it but we did this Ike is
five audio logs and now I'm like no damn
there is a lot more layers together it's
weird how when we talked to developers
and you start digging into the
intricacies of how they make certain
sequences or how they make their games
yeah you're like oh snap like I didn't
realize that you thought of that thing
this way and then when you go back and
play you're like oh yeah this was put
together by a person that I talked to
yes sort of Rod Fergusson about how they
were doing inclusive design courses at
the studio and throughout all of it
that's how Jack became a playable
character in Gears five and then because
then they just sort of worked on the
character more and more to make him
different and like more fun to play you
know even if you don't have a disability
and so it's eight episodes coming on
Sunday very good but we also had David
DeAngelo from Yacht Club games in the
studio today to film the shovel knight
episode and he was talking about all the
games that have inspired shovel Knight
and all the mechanics that inspired all
the mechanics within the treasure trove
and we had to do a ton of capture to
make sure that we got everything that he
wanted to talk about so between myself
tomorrow and Peter Brown we've played no
just going ham on shovel knight huh
time man she the bulk of it yes I I
hadn't picked it up until we started
like planning for this episode I did
like some of the play tonight stuff in
the spec tonight stuff and Tom got the
rest of the show of my stuff and pa was
like oh I could play NES games yeah yeah
that's fine give me a whole list it's
fine
now Sondra got some ninja gaiden for us
too it's a lot of fun and um yeah I've
got the treasure trove on my switch now
yeah amazing yeah I think spec tonight
and play ignite my favorites to play us
cuz I can't when I was just playing a
shovel knight I was really struggling to
sort of about the timing and the bounces
right and everything but this is I think
there's been more leniency at playing a
spectre and playing his played night
King night I didn't tell you that
because you were you were capturing king
of cards but I do want to play he's got
Wario shoulder bash I didn't know that
that's the one I haven't played yet
that's what the that's what the episode
is kind of a lot about what David
DeAngelo talks about it's like travel
night over this period that has been
releasing new games has just become this
collection of the best side-scrolling
platformer mechanics because it's like
and all like it's like this massive love
letter to classic games it's got like
ideas from Zelda 2 from Kirby 64 it's
caught like Wario ideas it's got
earthbound ideas Mario ideas Megaman
ideas like it's like a crash course in
in platformers and classic platforms NES
era onwards so like you don't really
when you take a step back and look at
the the French and he even describes it
as like we wanted to go back to games
that even people may not have liked at
the time right and find the thing that
was interesting but was never really
given the attention it deserved or
didn't get the opportunity to be refined
so the Zelda Pogo mechanic is the core
of shovelknight you know show justice
which everyone is from
ducktales but it's actually yeah it's
from Zelda - yeah shelf of hope is that
the whole thing is built on that
mechanic and it's the same for other
ideas like in and like the
spec tonight's kind of like you know -
mush mush
yeah the - is the move from the
and black and like it's just like taking
those ideas it's really interesting
almost like kind of like this collection
like educational collection about the
history of them platformers I love that
because I I always knew it was like
based on you know like oh yeah you know
it's Megaman isn't that but specifically
that it's based on a lot of mechanics
from like that they love but were from
games that maybe necessarily didn't
catch on I think it's so cool because I
think about that a lot of like you know
there are games that didn't hit with
people or weren't very good and and kind
of faded away but they had like this I
just one thing that was like actually
really cool and you're like man like I
wish more games brought that forward or
like you know explore that so I think
that's a really fascinating like game
philosophy I'll tell you what is they
like detailed breakdown game by game of
like inspiration travel no idea how they
got there so if you want like a crash
course and you want to see someone very
passionately talk about their love of
that genre and classic games watch the
episode of audio logs
alright let's say one news because they
looked at the the bankroll that they're
making from Final Fantasy 14 an Avengers
got delayed so remake got delayed by
like what a month oh yeah a month in a
few days delayed into September they all
supposed to come in May right or
something like a summer game but now
it's like a late summer game I'm too
surprised about Avengers I feel like
I've barely seen that game yeah
gameplay bit I haven't been 20 the
behind-closed-doors stuff but I saw that
like I don't know a bunch of people in a
car park
they had like a comic-con not recently
but like last middle not middle post III
like that was really revealed Kamala
Khan is like the main character and I
feel like that game it builds momentum
and then it just goes away
and then it builds momentum it goes away
I mean the weird thing were that game
for me is that like if it had come out
before game you would have been fine
because that was when everyone was still
thinking about the Avengers and thinking
about how the MCU is gonna wrap up yeah
and now it's this weird follow year
where end games happened you had that uh
Spider Man far from home
and then we've got nothing until like no
big ensemble things you've got a black
widow like not in humans yeah franchise
yet I would say um well then so it is
it's very very weird timing word games
specially good it's at yeah mmm Avengers
are and Marvel's heroes are eternally
popular and you stick them on the front
of the cover and the work gets done for
you easily so I like I don't doubt that
you'll be successful I just would love
to see more of that game it's getting
pushed a couple months yeah I mean yeah
yeah I yeah I don't know if it's that's
gonna be like a massive it's not that
big but it's not like oh we're
postponing it yeah definitely or yeah
pushing it to next year also it's like I
mean at least we'll probably find out
more easier goes on but right now like
there's that's the only game I'm aware
of that is scheduled to come out like
the later has April wait you know we
just don't know about anything speaking
of April I think it's like I remembered
looking at like games Wikipedia for like
we're that's like a good way to I do to
like look at like what's come out this
year and it's like after like May was
just like there was nothing nada
yeah well yeah and finally 7 remake for
March 3rd to April 10
I think I think I like yeah that's fine
but I'm thinking about us so that's the
thing you know mine that is being
delayed a month it's more like I sure
you made that way worse for us because
it was that was the first big game that
was coming out this year as far as us
covering it yeah you're like what if we
dropped it in the middle of everything
like first for some context like for us
we usually get games a bit early and
finalizes 7 remake was supposed to be
like with the first of the wave and then
that would have been like okay we can
knock out all the stuff we want to do a
round Final Fantasy 7 remake before we
start to dive into doom eternal and I'm
glossing p5 our cyberpunk or as an evil
3 but now it's like actually we're gonna
drop that between resonable 3 and some
puns so good luck y'all
I think cyberpunk is gonna get delayed i
but anyway for us is tricky but like
think of it from the people who are like
just playing games they're gonna be bi
it they're gonna have a great month is
gonna look real dry though Bayonetta and
vanquish bundle oh I just resolved if
you have played Baena
maybe like 10 times at this point if you
haven't played at those games holder I
mean also very good really champion
you should talk talk to talk to my
Spinelli he loves that game he does and
I'm talking to him he like cuz I never
played it and then like hearing him
enthusiastically talk about it is when
they did the PC port yeah and I was like
oh okay like alright you're selling me
on and then I played and was like oh
yeah like I'm feeling it like it's you
know Platinum's take on a cover shooter
and all it's pretty well done yeah Sam
Gideon slot real real drill dumb yep
that's some slipping and sliding in that
game
yeah so Final Fantasy 7 remake delayed
slightly but probably be better so yeah
oh my god no out here come on stick
stick to tampons can't Tampax
you know ultra flow no you credited name
my favorite bit
Oh cuz you have such a great name that
conveys so much a mutual friend of ours
in the UK just tweeted how is it the
time I was saying can just make puns and
his own name and no one says anything
yeah if you do if you do it long enough
people just like he's just just doing it
Yoshinori Kitase a had a statement as
well regarding the final phase of 7
remake delay nah dawg cutting you off
bro us the last time you make a pun in
this episode we're making this tough
decision in order to give ourselves a
few extra weeks to apply final polish to
the game and to deliver you the best
possible experience ketosis on said with
a message to studio I on behalf of the
whole team once you apologize to
everyone yes alright man as I know this
means waiting for the game a little bit
longer thank you for your patience and
continued support dog people been
waiting for this games
yeah believe you when they put out the
March 3rd release date I was like yo
this game is real it's really real fun
really yeah I mean I do I played the PAX
West we played the PAX West you were in
VR the hold on Dan they drugged you
right
Smash Brothers so I guess this is making
a guess because by the time this podcast
goes up
oh is that that's what we're doing
tomorrow that's yeah
by the time this podcast goes up the
smash character will have been revealed
but we can all make one guess each why
yes each hard drive did a great tweet
about it it was a new smash for this
character revealed to be that one guy
who only wants to play bro I had the
funniest thing the second or last day
before the end of the year it was bring
your kid to work day
you fool your kid no yeah I brought my
kid a secret family kids and I basically
ended up being the person who somehow
like I set up like a bunch of switches
for the kids to play right so like Mario
Kart I set up like smash bros and I was
like all right for smash we'll just plug
in these you know GameCube controllers
just the easiest way to make it work
yeah and then these kids they must have
been like five they were like these are
some weird controllers right grandpa we
want joy Kahn's
yeah not this no matter anymore I mean I
think the most likely can I say most
likely and then to who I would want yeah
most liked everyone I think is Dante
because I you time it with that EMC
drink the dmc3 thing they were talking
about they're gonna have a couple
different announcements I think one of
those dates maybe lines tomorrow if I
had a pic though I kind of want Travis
touchdown hey that's good man cuz suit
it cuz cuz number here's three is coming
out this year he could still make it in
the the second DLC pack so if he doesn't
make it in I I still have hope but sure
that's that's the sword boy I'd like to
be here some good good guesses I think
most likely Oh what I think could work
is a gym leader from sword and shield
yeah like a new pokemon pokemon trainer
but it's a gym leader and said
generic trainer it'll be one of them and
the switch between the three Pokemon
like like the pokemon trainer did in
brawl okay cuz it had like was it hey
Vsauce squirrel and Charizard you get
like three new era Pokemon but Pokemon
do you think of a beer it's not three
korbinites okay you like bring your
money immediately just roll who do I
want I want a blood war character yeah
[Laughter]
the astral Clocktower get her in just
absolutely destroying it yeah I want
lady marina lady Maria in smash I know
how to make Tam happy yeah my god do you
want oh did you want to do two guesses
like I know I did it I did it damn
Pokemon training Pokemon gym leader oh
okay lady Marie of the asteroid oh yeah
I think a Pokemon another Pokemon
Pokemon showing up at some point is very
likely even if not immediately
speaking of Astral things I would
actually want to see I mean there would
probably be not many reasons to do this
but the main characters from astral
chain some cops some cops don't put that
on me hey I'm just saying it makes the
are they a cop or not chart real easy to
figure out but I think because those
Astrachan has a lot of dope abilities
that would translate really well with
smash bros so after cheney's a little
bit more love come on that's fine I have
been meaning to plan nothing but
Astrachan haters in her game of the year
discussions man tam yeah hey you were
the only two people who played it was
dope damn
alright well Dante's a really good guest
like an annoyingly good guess he said
he's wrapped up in PlayStation also
about real nice and see know
that was the other dante dante basco and
you go yeah yeah that was that was Dante
it wasn't that one what is up what was
like deku deku got in before go ha ha
New Age anime in terms of like a weird
thing that you couldn't really see
coming I would be interested see if like
a Microsoft like an Xbox character I got
Steve from minecraft people keep saying
Master Chief and I'm like like
legitimately and I'm like I don't know I
don't see that was a master chief though
that was a different Spartans just spawn
it was a Spartan issue it was a female
because you can like Steve that would be
very fast I can't see any call from like
Lego like it like it come in like go
game sick that would give me a pipe of
[ __ ] just entire Xbox series si Phil
Spencer I think I'll be so adorable he
could be like one of the me fighters
yeah yeah
and then his ultimate smash attack is is
the Xbox one extra brushes that that's
really cute I like that hey Jenelle
Sinestro
[Music]
final destination it was in the works
all these years
all right final news story Sony not
coming back to e3
not really that much of a surprise no
huge surprise or nothing we need to help
maybe much about I mean like they were
they in Austria yeah but I was like oh
this is ps5 year though if I recall ask
for the wording was like kind of implied
that like they didn't do it last year
because he just didn't have much to
because they had okay they didn't even
do PSX last year yeah like they did
nothing so it was like oh maybe they're
just taking a break because they just
realize they had nothing that was why
they didn't do last year and then this
year they're like whoa we got a ps5 we
should do it this year and they're like
what if we just don't though like no no
actually that we saved a lot of money we
could just do our own event yeah yeah I
think it is a lot like Eddie makuu on
news team brought up a great feature on
why I was right the right move to do
that it's on GameSpot um you can read
that and it pretty much breaks down you
know the history of Sony's the kind of
decision to not be III and why it makes
sense for them and yeah and it
effectively means it works out better
for all of us cuz they don't have to
share the spotlight with Microsoft
Microsoft gets to own III for Xbox
series X and so on you can do their own
thing and no one's paying you know crazy
amounts exorbitant to be there and like
controlling messages clearer messages
around that time later yeah it
definitely helps us with the amount of
things that we have to cover it
regardless of how busy III looks from
outsider's perspective we always have to
fill our time with something yeah so
it's little I guess I don't know -
inside baseball but it makes it a little
easier to like okay we want to focus on
these videos Xbox series X we're gonna
like you know do as much stuff as we can
around during that show but when you
packed a whole console year and both of
them's at e3 boy got a lot of work cut
out for you yeah oh yeah there's a
statement from from Sony themselves
from mr. Sony itself yeah Steve Sony
said after thorough evaluation s ie Sony
was it Sony interactive entertainment
has decided not to participate in the e3
2020 so nice it continued we have great
respect for the ESA as an organization
but we do not feel the vision of e3 2020
is the right venue for what we are
focused on this year you hate to see it
we don't have to [ __ ] on any threes and
then I mean like statement and it was
like had the same energy as designer
singing panda it was just like yeah
we're good we're great we're fine
everything's good panda bye bye bye
designer why we tell my panel from this
I say the same energy it was just like
everything's fine okay when when do you
think they'll do the PS 5 proper
announcement but they also did B 3 that
years so maybe they do we solve the logo
at CES 2020 who knew if you had asked me
three years ago to draw the logo like
pixel precise even photoshopping
thumbnails that exact design so I think
they're gonna do it
I think I still think February cuz
February so pretty clear soon though
that's why they pushed last of us alike
hey y'all y'all y'all can put your
little game out later field it because
like Xbox has been made so ahead I think
May yeah just sneak in before e3 they
companies love doing that like we're
gonna come to the day before you play
thing Wow
damn I would not want bring back Peter
that be I said that last it's like hey
they don't bring my PSX cuz they need
some sort of Vinny to like flex real
hard maybe they do that this you know
maybe they don't even call PS is a this
is the reveal event or whatever yeah
people can come or you can watch the
livestream they did that for like
they've got a bit of practice with it
with the lost of us event right like
Dodger big thing where they flew loads
of people out from across the world to
this one thing you know played loss of
us send them on their way and cover
exhaust was to coming out do you think
they'll do it like right after a lot
like oh maybe right after like hey y'all
bout last of us to it's great now he's
be a survive like yeah I guess I see
like lost of us is out it's out is gonna
be working on ps5 speaker yes wife is
there 100% gonna do the same situation
they do yeah I reckon there was some
point one sword and shield stuff I gotta
leave that stuff for ya the expert on
lad
Jake and young les Kelly I dig into it I
played a few hours and then I can't
dropped off yeah as I always do that I
think it's the first Pokemon game in
mm not actually I liked X&Y a lot but I
saw some moon was okay but I I really
like this one that's really good all
right all right listening questions
Michael John Tate was first one sure all
right
hey after dark crew hope you had
wonderful holidays the discussion
episodes were interesting but it's nice
to have weekly discussion reserves to
say resume Wow yeah you know what I got
on my mind nice to have the quick nobs
psych I'm just kidding the weekly
discussion resumed this person has two
questions one do you tend to hoard items
and games always use them a SAP or
somewhere in the middle I was a hoarder
but have pushed against that instinct
and I think finally broke it with breath
of the wild number two so I connected to
that outside of work games how often do
you stop playing a game before
quote-unquote completing it happy 2020
sky and PS oh wait some more I offer to
run a D&D game for you but you were all
over the world and have not been on the
podcast since then I would be bummed and
not to have chill
if you wanted to play pretend on the
internet but just miss the question
because of the hectic holiday maybe
we'll take you up on that maybe we keep
talking about running a cyberpunk game
sorry Paul I think Ryan was gonna be
yeah so hoarding items and games yeah
yeah except which I broke that for me
because if the way that potions
replenish when you yeah you don't have
to worry that's a good point you were
strong enough for the strongest potions
oceans Ella is how many asteroids
parishes traveler
all right I've been I'd be mad hoarding
in the games it's the same thing of like
me I'm gonna use this for the final boss
fight and they turn out like AI mopey
for the final boss fight I got like 20
super mega elixirs and I'm just chillin
I don't know it's it's fine but I've
tried to break that and playing a lot of
RPGs now I'm like [ __ ] and I'm gonna use
the
the revival bead in this blame ass fight
because I have six of them and I'll have
five of them when I do fight the boss
may name the Sakura I am and then said
lame-ass fight wave of revival beads are
[Music]
relaxed well I mean if you get live up
to them after dark you know I'm saying
but I'll be flexing on the items and was
like plain oh it's plain Tokyo Mirage
sessions and there was a there was a
boss that killed one of my party members
like five times and only had like five
spicy curries to revive that person so I
use all five of my spicy curries and I
was like damn should I reload and do
that boss fight again and not used as
many spicy curries but then it turns out
I could just buy it at the epic eHome
art the character was like I'm alive but
I really curries there's a lot of SMT
and fire in Loretto and I started work
games how often do you stop playing game
before quote-unquote completing it I'm
really mad at starting games and not
finishing him so yeah completely I think
between us like the fact that we both
complete Andromeda says a lot about us
it's true it depends on the game like
Andromeda was a weird I don't know what
I was thinking cuz like I should have
stopped yes just because I should have I
could have just beaten at any point but
I was like no I'm gonna 100% every
planet because god damnit I'm gonna do
this I don't know why though you know
it's funny of when it comes to
completing games recently for me it's
been I started gameplay the first two
hours and either drop off or played all
the way through um since we're talking
my Mass Effect 3 what happened with me
in Mass Effect 3 is I bought at the day
up in 2012 and I was like y'all Isis
this is it man this is the end of Mass
Effect trilogy I played it about 60 or
70 percent of the way through doing
every single quest like yeah I'm leave
no stone unturned and then I got to a
point where like my military
was at like Max and I'm like all right
I'm gonna I'm bout to like finish this
game and see it through house in 2012
and I didn't pick it up until 2016
because the thing for me was like yo if
I don't it's a lot of people talk about
this but like if I don't finish the game
it never ends
and I did I I didn't want mass effect to
end I'm just like yo even the best part
was that by 2016 all the DLC had come
out so then I did love I did shout out
to Joe so and but like when I want to
got back to in 2016 actually restarted
in bastard group with my saves from one
and two from back in the day so then it
took me four years to finish Mass Effect
I'm glad I did because I got all the DLC
and I was like I don't know why I'll
trip it about the ending it was like
well I patched anyway but yeah that's
but now I've learned from that that you
know I just just finished that game if
you're like halfway through just keep
going yeah I mean I've definitely
learned I think the issue with me was
more I had this mindset were like I
should finish this game even if I wasn't
feeling it mmm and I've gotten rid of
that of like no I don't like this game
like why I shouldn't why do I feel
obligated to like finish it you know
even if I don't like the game I like
having the knowledge of how that game
turned out yeah because I could use that
knowledge in whatever like maybe I
review another game then the similar
vein and I have that reference in my
mind of like oh I remember how that game
ended how this like in comparison I
could maybe I talk about it be brought
up later down the line so I do see value
in finishing games even if you don't
necessarily like them but that's for
people like us like if you're out there
playing the game guys I don't know
because I'm kinda like I have like ADHD
which I think leads to this like
slightly compulsive liar yeah I I like I
have to make checklist for myself to
feel organized and part of its like
completing things so like I feel like if
I don't finish a game I know it's like
in the back of like mind it's like this
checklist of like I need to finish it so
I can check it off and I can feel better
about myself so like I have this weird
like I still have like a massive backlog
of games that I like
haven't touched in four years but I'm
like no one day I will finish that game
so I'll feel slightly better about
myself I have so many Google keep notes
of just a games books I want to read the
whole thing yeah my Microsoft OneNote is
full of like stuff bullet journaling
yeah but generally mmm all right I'm
gonna take this next question this is a
questions for Callie so I'm gonna skip
that one it's not it just says that they
enjoy hearing Kelly hi everyone I want
to say first off how excited I am to
hear Kelly again I usually listen to the
IGN anime podcast are you an anime club
and was sad when it was over my husband
heard Kelly's voice and told me she's on
in this new podcast so I had to listen
Oh lovely you guys really great and very
entertaining I'm on the market for new
headphones and wonder what everyone else
was bonus points if you add in ones that
used to work out in - thanks again for a
great podcast
Alysia kunu michael you got them new
headphones you've been messing with is
to be the e tech editor at GameSpot so I
got mad headphones I had seven wasn't
seven headphones in only two years
who'da thunk it like I got so weird no
microphone but no microphone yeah every
time I don't have a microphone I'm not
have a microphone hey chill chill chill
we playin like hella halo reach and
everyone else got microphones I'm the
one blah I'm blowing up the discord text
chat and I'm like I'm like laughing my
ass off while playing Halo Reach but I
cannot express it vocally to who I'm
playing with so I'm like hahaha lol
lmfao
just do the thing where you move the
looking
when we play apex we're playing over the
holidays and I'm playing with Tom and
cop friend of the podcast I'm McCarty
and I had some friends round at my house
and I didn't use a mic and so I remember
what it was but I died and I if you hold
down the touchpad to be playing on ps4
it brings up the little key oh yeah and
so I was doing this like predictive text
thing or I was just and then inevitably
I would die and I would just go sorry
again
sorry sorry sorry
terms of headphones we be using though I
tested a lot of headphones I think for a
gaming I mean for anything really I like
to use audio technica I think like m50x
for a closed ear the sennheiser HD 5 9/8
or have been for many years lauded as
some of the best open hear headphones I
mean yeah for better a very good
soundstage I guess you could say I like
hyper X's headphones a lot the cloud
twos are pretty good I was just
double-checking
well the name was but I'd choose an echo
yeah that's gonna use my so they're
comfy and they they don't they don't
clamp too hard and they sound pretty
these clamps and yeah though those are
the ones that I would recommend also on
gamespot comm we have a list of
headphones that we would recommend
depending on your price range what
you're looking for in those headsets as
a Michael hi I'm Edmund Tran Peter Brown
and Matt pageant joint a lab in but yeah
I think all of what we work out and so
when I used to I used earbuds when I
used to run yeah well I said wrong with
headphones I was like this this is I'm
just like constantly shifting them yeah
and I got like mad sweaty so yeah like
you I always use the air buds when I was
using when I'm working out because like
you generate heat when you're working
out yeah like if you've got things
clamping over your head it's just give
me a headache they get all gross I use
the cloud the HyperX ones clubs and
they're real good for gaming for working
out I used like I called Jabra Jabra
j-bert Jay but yeah
so those are good I like them a lot the
only problem of the Jaybirds is I think
it's still a problem with the new ones
specifically on the YouTube app it has
problems synchronizing sound and video
Oh
which is really annoying because it's
final Netflix but its YouTube
specifically is a problem but they're
very comfortable
we should be affordable if you want to
work out but I don't think there's a con
think of many headphones that do both
gaming and are good for work and yeah
you need to buy em plus you don't want
to be using your workout headphones when
you be game as a kind of you could rock
up into a gym wearing some hardcore like
gaming headphones it might be like with
the microphone I win a microphone just
like boys people discord app I don't
know I use I use I can't use any Apple
earbuds for working out or because I'm a
big was used to be a marathon runner now
I mean maybe a quarter marathon runner
at this point getting too old but I need
you definitely want earbuds that have
like the the suction cups on them
because otherwise all the Apple [ __ ] is
like enough that's just a fall out your
ear if you'd be running with ear pods
you going to lose them yeah I have the
only place I use them is in the office
cuz the battery life I'm one of those
people who needs music on cuz I just get
distracted otherwise I just have I just
basically this into the west-world
playlist over and over again because
it's just enough for me to keep me
engaged but not distract me air pods the
battery life is not good enough for me
for that but it lasts the right amount
of time that I'm in the office and also
if someone comes over to me it's super
easy just to take it out and it pauses I
will say this is not like a gaming
recommendation or a even an everyday
recommendation but the Sennheiser noise
cancelling ones on it's a bose
noise-canceling ones I bought a pair
like 2018 Christmas because I was like
I'm about to fly back to the UK it's a
10-hour flight I want to be able to hear
whatever I'm playing and it's probably
one of the best purchases I've ever made
also the battery life is like 12 hours
with full no
counseling on and I wouldn't say wear it
in you know on the bus or anything you
should still have some situational
awareness but if you travel a lot noise
cancelling headphones are the boy all
right Johnny let's question sure
actually we have a couple questions
because time put a tweet and there was
some really good one Oh rapid-fire will
do and then we'll do times rapid
violence hello gamespot crew what's your
favorite console gaming chair set up my
lazy boy is comfortable but recently I
am looking for something with more lower
back support
thanks for the weekly laughs everyone
there is so great cheers Anthony E from
California
hi Anthony E from California I have a
terrible gaming sub because I sit on my
bed so I'm old my pillows around its
really bad but it's also just the way
that my room is set up yeah I just have
a couch for console stuff Dave so Dave
do it
moved into my old room okay and when I
was back for Christmas there was a
couple days where there was crossover
and Dave brought his gaming chair and I
need to find out what make it was
because I sat down on it and it was like
sitting on a cloud with lumbar support
that's the eyes that's when I sat in
when yeah and I was like this is yeah
when you came over me watch yeah this is
like this is the one like buddy I get
very expensive though
yeah mine's a bed as well I have a I
have a weak-ass staples chair but it's
mesh and I like that because it's a
little bit more breathable but my cat
loves it very much
sushi Wu she loves to claw at it I'm
like dog I go too bad huh sure I go to
the bathroom in like in 30 seconds she's
on it and she's all cozy and stuff so
I'm gonna play good on audio but if you
all can see picture right there there's
my my little cat sushi sushi chilling on
my chair I just went to the bathroom
which is like my C now haha do something
do something and I was like oh but yeah
I need upgrade should you stop sitting
that [ __ ] man yeah we all need better I
think Jack rapid-fire questions
I mean it's just basically because a lot
of people asked you about the same thing
I'm not gonna answer that I just know
it's not gonna be indulgent podcast
about me I mean actually I'm concerned
the fact that max Scoville called a
cheese grater
yeah like a plus greater or that's the
East Coast thing oh wait yeah I say
grater cheese grater so over like that
question is though I wasn't think of
that max Scoville you're teasing he
spelled it out okay interesting he says
what's up with a cheese grater banana
nonsense it's just a superior way to you
but is it is what it is
get with it I'm an innovator 1 in line
man's hot I like this one which is how
do you keep your hair so majestically
swooshed tomorrow all right I think
really does nothing if you got close
enough you realize that the TAM just
rolls with it man he doesn't it's like
yeah camera makes it look good but via
clothes like stinky Crowsnest tam does
not give a [ __ ] he makes it look good
captain Badman great that's a desk
trending character yeah Sam it's me
captain Badman what are your
expectations for no games as a service
and next-gen well current popular titles
be poured over made available quickfire
yes now yeah yeah yeah yes yes they'll
be there yeah great and Morales says if
y'all had to choose a Pokemon based off
each other's personalities
what would the Pokemon be so well if you
were a Pokemon based on your personally
what one would Lucy be Oh
wowsie be onyx that's like it's all neck
I'm sorry I like it but actually doesn't
[ __ ] this fool up right now no I do like
it but the real answer is Snorlax last
week when I was sick I was sleeping for
12 hours a day at least and it was
well we were on the fly and like I like
strapped in for for takeoff and then I
was like looking and Lucy was pointing a
bell in and I'd like a justed my C and
she's asleep
yeah oh that was because I'd been in LA
and I hadn't slept for like the previous
two nights and I had to be up at 6:00
mmm yeah I'm gonna sleep on this way
josephus says knife versus bat which one
wins knife vs. bad yeah versus an animal
no no no like like a baseball bat my
twins spot score right III agree bat I
still feel the same way I do back when I
cuz you if you swing the bat and
overshoot but you've got the knife
you've got that Club if you have the
knife and you dodged the bat then you
just shake I talked about hating slides
too much precision that's yeah you get
[ __ ] up for sure look you can take a
swing with a bat miss and still have
enough time to recover and take another
swing yeah dude it's like letting go
over the bar the end it's like sword art
yeah we're not sword art the anime but
like the art of the blade the thing is I
think it's it's a real like high
pressure scenario of like whoever misses
first loses kind of sure like I think
you know what if the answer was knife
and bat is equal justice mouseka how
skilled you wait the elusive knife bat
you can last one last question
let's keep here someone's keep it on
brand any game recommendations for fans
who love Sakura but couldn't get into
Dark Souls
if the answer is easy baby it's actually
trails of cold steel it's definitely not
where it's blood bone baby
The Legend of Heroes trails said no
Ninja Gaiden may be like any platinum
game a platinum action voucher a good
like Metal Gear Rising
a that came from Newton by the way and
final question
Oh PS now 85 mm-hmm says who is best
waifu in persona 5 and why is it makoto
it's actually let me let me show you my
background it's actually her sister so I
need you mom she's literally a cop she's
paying rent she might even own that
house that they live in
she's got gray hair and eye red eyes and
like by default that's that's oh that's
a win in my book you know like she got a
job she's already done with high school
she's paying rent she's got her things
for you a she kind of thinks figure she
figures out by the end and she's got
gray hair and red eyes like makoto's got
short hair and looks phenomenal
Yeah right but Syene injury was like 25
27 and that's mine I think by the time
Mikoto gets to the edge Tajima is way
better for watching the video business
podcast you will see the exact moment
that I accidentally scroll past on
Twitter where it's mined hunter cast
released from contracts as season 3 is
put on indefinite hold at Netflix no oh
no mind Hunter season 2 and if that's
true
I fished it further away from me and I
was like sign iijima well I mean like a
final question
[Music]
you said that like three times now you
know I'm just gonna keep doing this I
need right
there's no final question the final
question is from Pete Stewart our friend
he says can dogs look up no I can't
sadly I'm lucky for dogs what what do
you mean they can't look up can you can
you ever seen a dog look up yeah they
look up at me when they're asking for
dogs
darhk's can look out yeah they can is
that an up dog joke like what's up
though yes I'm done with damn dog all
right
calling it there thank you everyone for
listening and watching to GameSpot after
dark if you have any questions email
them to after dr. podcast at
gamespot.com
or tweet them to us we love hearing from
you and chatting with you guys
discord update so some people emailing
for discord in by joining I I just need
I need to get the final approval from
from the powers powers that be house
doesn't work here anymore Michael powers
hope you Charlie Charlie CBS is lacking
yeah Charlie Viacom CBS Oh
give it time yeah not long we'll push
for it all right thank you everyone for
joining us let's start from this end
John the quack people find you at Sonic
psyche at Tomoya h you can find me at
all about [ __ ] at Michael P hi I'm
on Twitter and I'm Melissa James games
thank you for watching slash listening
we'll see you next week Reaper
indoctrination is an insidious piece of
corrupting organic mine
[Music]